ainsi chez vous il a un groove d'enfer
il est maintenant une révélation
radio-canada robert pourquoi du temps
les louanges balayage c'est assez c'est
assez obscur de saviem et pour faire
simple c'est moi c'est tellement mon
surnom a fait que j'ai eu toute mon
adolescence avec son surnom les louanges
le jeune homme de 23 ans originaire de
lévis fusionnent savamment le funk le
jazz le r'n'b et même un peu le hip hop
comme un diplôme un musée gus
d'extension j'avais couler une cours de
composition et le plus paradoxal après
avoir participé au festival
international de la chanson de granby et
les francouvertes les louanges est vite
remarqué par l'étiquette de disques bon
sens qui compte entre autres dans son
écurie
lisa leblanc et sa fille n 1 j'ai besoin
de quelqu'un qui allait me donner un
couloir dans lequel courir chacun doit
être un bon cheval sur lequel parier
dites moi j'ose dans quelle direction
courir
dans ma chambre
l'automne dernier il a lancé son premier
disque la nuit est une panthère qui est
considéré comme l'un des meilleurs
albums de 2018
la tuque bleue vissée sur la tête et le
roule maintenant à un train d'enfer
[Musique]
en quelques mois il a donné des
spectacles en france et aux états unis
en plus de composer la trame sonore du
prochain film d'anne émond jeune
juliette en studio il bricole
actuellement un mini album c'est que tu
es en année pourrait prochainement avoir
une vision à long terme
j'ai l'impression ça fait 15 9 et
commencé tout seul le mad ap les
louanges reçoit aujourd'hui les éloges
des honneurs qui lui permettront de se
faire voir et surtout entendre sur
toutes les plateformes de radio-canada
ici julie jasmin boudreau radio canada
montréal
[Applaudissements]